[Music]
well thank you very much for coming um i
was going to originally to talk about my
two books which are really about the
interrelationship between economics and
politics but i i'm gonna make it much
more topical
uh and i think a useful starting point
is a comment that was made
a couple of days ago by a man called
jamie diamond on a dimmer who is head of
one of the leading wells leading
investment banks
he said an economic hurricane is heading
our way well you may think you know
following the level of debate in the uk
that the hurricane's already here but
the argument is that there's something
much bigger coming in our direction
and i just want to talk about that
whether it's plausible or it amounts to
and i think the best way to
at least the way i understand it is in
terms of
a series of layers of problems
because at the bottom we've got what
we're already living through which is
so-called cost of living crisis
and then superimposed on that we've had
the first
impacts of the war in ukraine
and then superimposed on that and just
beginning to be apparent
uh is the the second stage of the war as
if
as we get energy sanctions because we
haven't really got any sanctions yet
combined with the impact on food the big
thing which is only just beginning to
become apparent
and i think i think on top of that there
are some
other layers bigger things that are
happening one is the so-called great
chisholm
which is opening up between china and
its allies which include russia
and the western world
and the impact of that into
an economic connection
the phenomenon of circle
de-globalization which people argue is
happening the evidence is a bit mixed
but
the the world economies aren't picking
and then on top of everything and there
are these big global existential things
we're all worried about like climate
change which are kind of radically
affected really by the war and the
things around it but let me start with
the
cost of living crisis the
the inflation shock that we're living
through it i mean the way the way i see
it happening is that there's been a big
pumped up increase in demand as we
recover from the
pandemic
and it's been helped by the fact that
all the money was pumped into the
economy cheap and interest rates really
go negative after inflation
abiding stimulus packaged lots of money
being poured in on top of all the
quantitative easing we've had ever since
the financial crisis so you've got a
recovery fueled by this stuff
and then at the same time all kind of
blockages
preventing
stuff being produced and the combination
of the two things is producing inflation
uh one kind of image that i have which
helps me to understand it is a bit those
of you who've ever
been in a motorway queue on the m25
particularly you get a collision you get
an obstacle everything grants to a whole
people panning at the end of the queue
and then two or three hours later you
know
the trouble has been cleared away
but we don't all just smoothly then
glide away it takes hours and hours to
clear it because
you're stopping and starting and some
idiots trying to jump from one lane to
the other to get a few seconds and
that's a little bit what's happening
with the world economy at the moment
and there are some very specific things
that are making this a lot worse
one of them is what's been happening in
natural gas
because last year we didn't really
notice it at the time
but the russian supply of natural gas
through the pipelines was cut by about
15
also the storage in europe was cut by
about 25 below what it normally is
most of it's actually owned by gas crops
so you don't really need to be a
conspiracy theorist to work out what's
happening
so natural gas
prices showed up
europeans scouted shopping in the middle
east
but then they were competing with china
and japan so that pushed out the price
of liquid natural gas and so we had this
upsurge of gas prices which forms the
basis of the wholesale prices for
electricity and of course gas in the uk
which is what we've all experienced and
they're going to see more of in the
autumn
so part of it was gas then you've got
the issues around the old market
we thought that all the problems that
used to exist with opec and oil shops
have all gone away
because of all these american shell oil
producers and so on but
actually what happened is that in the
last collapse of the oil market they
shave shadow companies basically closed
down
and when the sudden up surgery demand is
nothing to produce
in addition the americans have
sanctioned venezuela and iran which is
actually there's another blockage
and in addition something that's been
quietly going on
which is that a new kind of opec has
been created with an alliance between
saudi arabia and
russia we always used to think of saudi
as being sort of best friends of the
western world but that has changed quite
radically not because of prince mohammed
personally
but china is now their main customer
america doesn't really figure in terms
of what they produce and consume
um and so they've teamed up with the
russians to try to manage the world's
live oil
so the combination of these restrictions
and their rapid upsurge of demand is
also for low prices to go shooting up
which is what you see at petrol pump
and is already causing rage in the
united states which is where biden's
people will probably get better than the
autumn so we've got the the oil shop
um in addition to that a whole lot of
other things have been blocked
from getting out of china because of the
pandemic close down
president xi has made a terrible
mass actually they kill videos thought
initially was doing brilliantly but the
zero covered has meant that they are
having to insulate cities people can't
get to work production isn't getting out
all the supply chains have been
disrupted
and then there are some very specific
blockages and semiconductors
other things
and all of this is adding to this sort
of inflationary
push in the world economist not just the
uk i mean one way i think of it is it's
a bit a bit as if the whole world
has just seen a big increase in indirect
taxes the value-added tax increase on
the world
and what's it done it's pushed at prices
everywhere
uh and it's also sucked out quite a lot
of spending people worse off so they
spend less so we've got the combination
of inflation
and stamp inflation of stagnation and
possibility the real possibility now of
recession coming in probably quite a
serious recession towards the end of the
year beginning of next year these two
things happening at the same time
i did to which
western governments are getting
seriously alarmed about inflation they
remember what happened back in the late
70s
so they're jacking up interest rates
quite rapidly and that in turn is
producing the pressures leading to
recession and deflation
so that's the first layer
combination of inflation from the
potential
recession we shot coming
then we had the war
um so far that the war has had
only fairly indirect and modest effects
on us but it's going to grow
basically what's happened so far is that
because people in the markets have
tended to worry that there are other
sanctions of gas sanctions coming
they've been busily building up stocks
and that's pushed out the price
in addition to that what what has been
highly effective from the point of view
of the western economies
is that
the the the europeans and americans have
hit the russians with
uh financial sanctions which have really
worked and in um
quite a brutal way effectively what's
happened is that russian property
including their foreign exchange reserve
has simply been expropriated
there's some worry about in the long run
about what this does about the
rights of ownership and capitalist
system but anyway it's worked the
russian foreign exchange reserves were
seized
individual private property has been
seized it's very difficult to
russians and russian businesses to make
transactions
uh people trying to export from russia
can't export because they can't do the
currency transactions the so-called
swift clearance system has been blocked
for the russians
so there are very severe financial
sections which are beginning to
really get through to them but that's
only the first stage to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas